مع دخول الصراع شعره الثالث الجيش يتهم
الدعم السريع باختطاف واغتيال والي غرب
دارفور والامم المتحده تحذر من جرائم ضد
الانسانيه في الاقليم
في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه موسكو تتعهد
بالقضاء على الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد فيما
يؤكدان تحقيق مكاسب على الارض
رئيس بلديه ميامي يترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه عن الحزب الجمهوري
لينضم الى عشره مرشحين اخرين في مواجهه
توم
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره اخباريه من العربيه قالت تحالف
السوداني الذي كان يراسه الوالي خميس عبد
الله ابكر ان ميليشيا الدعم السريع قامت
بقتل الوالي في مدينه الجنينه
واستنكرت السلوك الذي وصفته بانه يتنافى
مع المواثيق الدوليه في التعامل مع الاسرع
في السياقه لحسن ابراهيم فضل النائب امين
الاعلام في حركه العدل والمساواه
السودانيه انها ميليشيات مسلحه قتلت والي
غار دارفور خميس في مدينه الجنينه بولايه
غربي دارفور بعد ان اقتحمت ميليشيات
المسلحه مقر اقامتي الوالي الجنرال خميس
ابكر واختطفته وذهبت به الى جهه مجهوله
كما دانت حركه العدل والمساوات عمليات
للقتل الواسعه ونهب ممتلكات المدنيين
العزل وتشردهم على اساس الهويه والعرق
وحرق القرى وتدمير المستشفيات والمؤسسات
الخدميه خلال الايام الماضيه في غرب
دارفور
[موسيقى]
دخلت الازمه السودانيه الشهر الثالث اليوم
بعمليه اعتقال واختيال راح ضحيتها ولغرب
دارفور خميس عبد الله ابكر وذلك وسط تبادل
لالتهامات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
بشانه من نفذ عمليه الاغتيال
مقتل والي غرب درفور في الجنينه وطرف
الصراع في السودان يتهمان بعضهما
الجيش السوداني اكد ان قوات الدعم السريع
هي من اعتقلت واختلت خميس عبد الله ابكر
في عمليه وحشيه ندين حادثه الاغتيال ولا
علاقه لوال غرب دارفور بمجريات الصراع
الحاليه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
اما مستشار قوات الدعم السريع عمران عبد
الله حسن فحمل الجيش مسؤوليه مقتل ابكر
وقال ان السودان يعيش في حاله حرب ولا
مكان امن في دارفور عناصر متفلته تقف خلف
مقتل والي غرب دارفور من جهتها حركه العدل
والمساواه السودانيه اتهمت ميليشيات مسلحه
بالوقوف وراء الاغتيال اما التحالف
السوداني فدعا المجتمع الدولي للتحقيق في
مقتل والي غرب دارفور وشدد على انه يحتفظ
بحق الرد ابكر كان قد ناشر وقف اطلاق
النار في الجنينه وكشف تحت صوت الرصاص ان
القتال الدائر دمر المدينه باكملها اليوم
احنا عندنا اعداد كبيره جدا من الجرحى
مراكز الصينيه كلها تم تدميره تماما اليوم
جنينه كلها اتدمرت مدير الاعلان في حكومه
اقليم دارفور موسى داوود سلط الضوء على
الوضع الانساني الصعب في الجنينه واشار
بدوره الى ان عدد القتلى خلال المواجهات
بلغ اكثر من الف شخص
اذا دخلت الازمه السودانيه شعرها الثالث
اليوم بعمليه اعتقال اغتيال راح ضحيتها
والي غرب دارفور
[موسيقى]
جدد قائد سلاح المدفعيه في السودان اللواء
الركن محمد الامين حسن تاكيد القوات
المسلحه السودانيه على حسم المعركه ضد
قوات الدعم السريعه التي ما زالت ترفع
السلاح في وجه الجيش والشعب السوداني قال
قائد سلاح المدفعيه بمدينه عطبره ان رساله
الجيش السوداني لقوات الدعم السريع منذ
اول يوم في الحرب ان يضعوا السلاح وينضموا
الى القوات المسلحه السودانيه مؤكدا ان
حسم المعركه مع قوات الدعم السريع باتت
والشيكا لحس بقوله
السيده الهاي
ده العام لحظات الاولى اطلغ
رساله واضحه عن ضعوا السلاح وانضموا
لاخوانكم في القوات المسلحه الذين لبوا
هذا النداء الان هم اعزائي وعززين مكرمين
اخواني وجنودهم في القوات المسلحه
والذين ظلوا
يرفعون السلاح في وجهي
الشعب السوداني والقوات المسلحه سيتم
محاربه الا ان ينتهوا جميعا باذن الله
تعالى
يصوت البرلمان الاوروبي الخميس على مشروع
قرار يدين استمرار المعارك في السودان
وخرق طرفي الصراع الاتفاقات وقف النار كان
الاتحاد الاوروبي هدد بفرض عقوبات على
طرفي النزاع في السودان انتهاك القانون
الانساني الدولي وعرقله عمل الفرق الامميه
في ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه اضافه الى
اجبار اكثر من مليوني شخص على نزوح وفق
تقارير امميه
كما اكد سفير الامريكي في السودان جون
كودفري في تغريده على تويتر انه لا يوجد
حل عسكري مقبول للازمه السياسيه في
السودان وانه يجب ان يحدد المدنيون مستقبل
بلادهم
[موسيقى]
قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زغروفه في مقابله مع العربيه ان
العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا تهدف لوقف
اراقه الدماء في دون باس التي استمرت
لثمانيه اعوام اشارت صخروفه الى ان عده
دول قدمت رؤيتها في مبادرات لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه والمبادره الصينيه هي الاكثر
تماشيا مع نهج موسكو كما اضافت زخروفه ان
المبادره الصينيه تحترم سياده روسيا ولا
تؤجج الصراع كما قالت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه ان هناك مبادره لحل
الازمه قدمتها جنوب افريقيا وعن علاقات
موسكو بالدول العربيه اكدت تخروفان علاقات
روسيا بالدول العربيه مبنيه على الاحترام
المتبادل والمصالح المشتركه
الحرب في دومباس بدات منذ ثمان سنوات
بداتها كيف بتوجيه دباباتها بعد ان قام
الغرب والولايات المتحده بالانقلاب في
اوكرانيا قتل خلالها 15 الف شخص منهم عدد
كبير من المدنيين بدانا العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه من اجل ايقاف اراقه الدم لكن الغرب
استغل هذه الازمه من اجل بدء حرب هجينه
ضدنا ما يقومون به هو ضد اي دوله لها
سياسه خارجيه مستقله لذلك سينتهي الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد بانتصارنا لاننا على
الجانب الصحيح من التاريخ ولاننا ندافع عن
القيم العائليه والحريه الصادقه الخاليه
من الشر والعنف وندافع عن كل ما يعتبر
جزءا من حضارتنا
افادت مصادر لوكاله اكثر من 20 جنديا
اسيرا اوكرانيا سيمثلون اليوم امام محكمه
في جنوب روسيا اضافت المصادر ان الجنود
الاوكرانيون هم من كتيبه ازوف
ميدانيا اظهرت صور نشرتها صحيفه
اظهرت استسلامه جندي روسي طائرات اوكرانيه
بدون طيار في صحه معركه بخموت وقلقائد
الطائره الاوكرانيه وفق ما ذكر في تقرير
ورث جونيور قال ان الجندي الروسي ابدى
رغبه في انقاذ حياته بعدما باشارات باليد
تدل على الاستسلام في احدى خنادق صحه
المعارك في بخموت
كما نشرت الشرطه الاوكرانيه لقطات مثيره
تظهر عمليه انتشال امراه حيه من تحت
الانقاض قالت الشرطه انها انجدت امراه
ورجلا من تحت ركام مبان دمرتها ضربات
الروسيه على كارموتروسك خلال عمليه انقاذ
استمرت عده ساعات هناك
[موسيقى]
الى استراليا حيث من المقرر ان تمنع
الحكومات روسيا من بناء سفاره جديده قرب
البرلمان في كندا بسبب مخاوف امنيه تتعلق
بالامن القومي قال رئيس الوزراء الاسترالي
انطوني ان الحكومه
تلقت نصائح عاميه واضحه للغايه بشان
المخاطر التي يشكلها الوجود روسيا الجديد
في مكان قريب لهذه الدرجه من مبنى
البرلمان واضاف انه بعد ان سلكت حكومته كل
الطرق القانونيه الممكنه لمنع روسيا من
بناء سفاره جديده فانه يتبقى اقرار
تشريعات جديده في البرلمان
يعقد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ونظيره
الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون محادثات في
موسكو اليوم حيث سيتم التوقيع على اعلان
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين هذا
واكد رئيس الوزراء الروسي خلال لقائه
الرئيس تبون في وقت سابق على ان التوقيع
على اعلان شراكه الاستراتيجيه مع الجزائر
سيشكل خطوه مهمه مضيفا ان مواقف البلدين
من الاجنده الدوليه متقاربه كما رحب
باهتمام الجزائر بتوسيع التعاون مع
الاتحاد الاقتصادي الاوراسي مؤكدا ان
الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد سترحب بتطوير
التعاون مع الجزائر في عده مجلات
مستمر وفيها
في جلسه البحث عن رئيس لبنان لاول مره
يحضروا جميع النواب وتغيبوا الورق البيضاء
ومرشح المعارضه يتقدم على مرشح الممانعه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قدم رئيس بلديه مايامي
الرئاسيه الامريكيه اظهرت وثائق نشرتها
لجنه الانتخابات الفيدراليه الناس سواريز
قدم اوراق الترشحه يوم الاربعاء ووعد
سواريز انصاره باعلان ترشحه رسميا الخميس
في خطاب كبير دعاهم لحضوره وبذلك ينضموا
المحامي السابق فرانسيس سواريز الى نحو
عشره مرشحين جمهوريين لقطع الطريق على
ترامب الذي يتصدر السباق وبفارق كبير عنهم
جميعا بحسب استطلاعات الراي يذكر بان
سواريز هو ثالث مرشح من ولايه فلوريدا بعد
حاكم الولايه روندي سانتس ورئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب
على الجانب الاخر وفي المقابل كشف خبراء
في الشان الدستوري الامريكي كشفوا ان
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب لن
يواجه اي تهم تتعلق بالتجسس بشان الوثائق
السريه قال الخبراءين دونا ترامب كان يخزن
الوثائق السريه في منزله ولم يقم ببيعها
لاي دوله اجنبيه وهو الامر الذي يجعله
نسبيا خارج اطار المخاطر كونه لم يتهم
بالتجسس لصالح حكومه اجنبيه
[موسيقى]
هدد الاتحاد الاوروبي السلطات المعنيه في
كوسوفو بما اسمته عواقب سياسيه وذلك في
حال لم تتخذ اي قرارات لتهدئه التوترات
العسكريه في او مع المجموعه الصربيه في
الشمال قلم متحدث باسم مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف قال
ان هناك حاله من الانتظار لخفض تصعيد
العسكري
في لبنان ولاول مره يحضروا جميع النواب
وتغيب الورقه البيضاء من السباق الرئاسي
لتشهد الجلسه الثانيه عشر منافسه بين مرشح
المعارضه جهه ازعور مقابل مرشح ما يعرف
بمحور الممانعه سليمان الفرنجيه وفيما نجح
حزب الله بتقليص الفارق المتوقع الا انه
فشل في تامين اكثريه الاصوات التي نجح
ازور بالمحافظه عليها
هكذا بدت المنطقه المحيطه بمجلس النواب
صباح يوم الاربعاء اجراءات امنيه مكثفه
لمواكمه الجلسه الثانيه عشر لانتخاب رئيس
للجمهوريه الجلسه ليست حاسمه لكنها
بالتاكيد مختلفه عن ما سبق وبسلاح العدد
والتعداد طلبت موازين القوى
بخلاف المرات السابقه حضر جميع النواب
فهذه المره الاولى التي يكون فيها مرشح
بوجه مرشح بدلا من حرب الورقه البيضاء
نواب اتوا لدعم مرشح الاحزاب المسيحيه
والحزب الاشتراكي اضافه الى احزاب معارضه
ومستقله وعدد من التغييرين مقابل مرشح
محور الممانعه انتفاضه سياسيه برلمانيه
لتحرير لبنان من قبضه حزب الله من قبضه
محور الممانعه وقدرنا التقينا على شخصيه
ما بتنتمي لولا فريق من الافرقه وممكن
التفاهم مع على برنامج انقاذ اصلاحي هذا
المرشح هو مرشح عنده ما يكفي من مؤهلات
انه اولا يكون
بالايام اف بمسؤول عن 30 او 40 بلد واليوم
يكون مرشح وملتقى لكل هالقوى السياسيه
جهاد اسع
ور جهاد داخل انتصر ازعور على فرنجيه
بفارق ثمانيه اصوات نتيجه تظهر ان حزب
الله سعى الى تقليص الفارق رغم طلب رئيس
الطيار الوطني الحر جبران باسيل عالميه من
حزب الله عدم التدخل بشؤون حزبه الداخليه
ورشحنا جهاد ازور انتصر اليوم والخط
السياسي الذي يمثله انتصر اليوم
والعمليه الانتخابيه مش لازم ناخذها
بحسابيتها على على الكالكوليتر لازم ناخذ
انه نحن شو اخذنا 59 صوت ولازم هن يحسبوا
قديش اخذوا والاهم ليطلقوا هذا الدرس شو
ما اخذوا واللي ما اخذوه كثير كبير وهذا
دليل مفصلي على رفض لنهج
الممانعه
واختطاف لبنان باتجاهات غير ديمقراطيه
يحلوا الخامس عشر من يونيو دون ان ينجح
اللبنانيون بانتخابي رئيس ويبدو ان هذه
المده ستطول مع دعوه حزب الله للحوار
انطلاقا من مرشح الثنائي وعدم دعوه رئيس
مجلس النواب نبيه بري لجلسه ثانيه لانتخاب
رئيس للجمهوريه غنوه يتيم العربيه
قالت وسائل الاعلام الفلسطينيه ان قوه
اسرائيليه اقترح اقتحمت مدينه نابلس
بالضفه الغربيه من جهه الشرق معززه
بمدرعات وجرافات ما ادى الى وقوع اشتباكات
مسلحه مع الجنود الاسرائيليين بعد
محاصرتهم لاحد المنازل في المدينه في
الوقت نفسه قالت المصادر ان شابا فلسطينيا
اصيب برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه في مخيم
العين بنابلس افدت بوقوع انفجارات في
نابلس بعدما وصفته بانه اقتحام واسع
للمدينه
[موسيقى]
اعترفها وزير الماليه نيوزيلندي جراند ان
دخول البلاد الركود لم يكن مفاجاه اذا
اشارت الاحصائيات نيوزلانديه الى ان
الاقتصاد انكمش بنسبه 0.1% في الربع الاول
وذلك بعد انخفاض بنسبه
0.7% في نهايه العام الماضي ووفقا
للبيانات الرسميه تسببت فيضانات يناير في
اوكلينت والدمار الناجم عن اعصار جابرييل
في فبراير في حدوث انكماش واسع النطاق قبل
اشهر قليله من الانتخابات الوطنيه
حاله من الصدمه تخيم على السكان مدينه
نوتينغ هامل البريطانيه في وقت تواصل
الشرطه في المدينه استجواب المشتبه به
بارتكاب جرائم طعن اودت بحياه ثلاثه اشخاص
واصابه ثلاثه اخرين في عمليات دهس
اول جرائم الطعن كانت في هذا الشارع
لطالبين جامعيين في التاسعه عشره من العمر
اثناء عودتهما الى سكنهما الطلابي بعد
احتفالهما بنهايه الفصل الدراسي
الطالبان هما برنامج ويبر وجريس كومار لفظ
انفاسهما وسط صرخات مؤلمه ايقظت ساكنه هذا
الشارع عائله بارنابي وبر وصفت دمرها
الكامل في خطف حياه ابنها الشاب الجميل
واللامع في بدايه مرحله البلوغ والذي كان
يتطلع الى كل شيء في الحياه نادي هوكي
كانت جريس كومار تنتمي اليه عبر عن حزنه
الشديد لسماع خبر مقتل جريس الموهوبه
والمتفانيه المعروفه بالمرح والود
حفل تابيني احتضنته هذه الكنيسه وسط
نوتينغام غالبيه من حضروا هذا التجمع
التابينيه طلاب جامعيون يعرفون عن قرب او
عن بعد الضحيتين او مجرد التعبير عن
التضامن والوقوف ضد كل من يهدد سلامه سكان
هذه المدينه
اكثر من 400 شخص اضاءوا الشموع ووضعوا
باقات من الورود للتعبير عن مواساتهم لاسر
الضحايا مجرد انسان نحن لا نفهم ما حدث
والناس ارادوا ان يجتمعوا لتقديم التعازي
والمواساه والصلاه لما اصابنا من حزن
مشترك حقيقي في هذه الحادثه الضحيه
الثالثه هو في الستينيات من العمر تعتقد
الشظط ان المشتبه به الوحيده بارتكاب
عمليه الطعن والمعتقله لديها استخدم مركبه
الضحيه لدحس ثلاثه اشخاص احدهم في حاله
حرجه بينما اصابه اخرين كانت خفيفه
غالبيه الشوارع اعيد فتحها لحركه السير
بينما التحقيقات مستمره لمعرفه ظروف
ارتكاب ثلاث حوادث امنيه خطيره في المدينه
من مصطفى زارو العربيه
ارسل ستاره على قضيه شغلت الراي العام
المصريه يتعلق الامر بمقتل طالب المصريه
نير اشرف على يد زميلها محمد عادل الجهات
الامنيه المصريه نفذت حكم الاعدام بحق
الجاني وسلم جسمه لعائلته
بعد اقل من عام يزدل الستاره اخيرا على
القضيه التي هزت الراي العام في مصر
السلطات المصريه تعلن تنفيذ حكم الاعدام
ضد محمد اشرف الذي قتل زميلته نيره اشرف
في هذا المكان امام جامعه المنصوره
الجريمه تعود تفاصيلها لقتل المتهم للمجني
عليها بعد رفضها الارتباط به النيابه
احاله المتهم الى محكمه الجنايات وبعد اقل
من اسبوع تقررت احاله اوراق القضيه الى
المفتي وبعد صدور حكم الاعدام رفضت محكمه
النقض قبول الطعم اسره المتهم تسلمت
جثمانه من مستشفى المنصوره الدولي مصادر
صحفيه اشارت الى دخوله في حاله هستيريه
قبل الاعدام محامي اسره نيره يرى ان سرعه
تنفيذ حكم الاعدام تعد رساله من الدوله ضد
نوع جديد من الجرائم التي اثارت الخوف
داخل المجتمع كان لازم الدوله بيدي من
حديد تقول له استنوا وحاسبهم يا شباب ده
في دوله في قانون في قضاء مصري يقدر ان هو
يجزم ويحزم الامور دي كلها ويحازم الجريمه
في البلد والد نيره رحب بتنفيذ حكم
الاعدام واكدا انه شعر اخيرا بالعدل
والقصاص بعدما تعرضت له دييره من ظلم على
يد قاتلها وايضا من حملات التشهير التي
طالتها بعد وفاتها ومش القصاص الكامل لسه
هو القصاص من محمد علي لكن لسه بقيه الناس
اللي خاضوا في سيرتها وفي سمعتها وبشرفها
بس انا كان في نفسي النهارده الحق يبقى
كامل بان يتذاع جزء من تنفيذ حكم الاعدام
زي ما هي كل الناس شافتها في الحادثه
والعالم كله شافها كان في نفسي برضو انه
ده يتشاف وهو مش هو حتى بيتعدم هو داخل
على غرفه الاعدام ده اللي كان كنت بتمناه
اهالي المنصوره عبروا عن ساعدتهم بتنفيذ
الحكم ولكن بقي الانقسام حول كونه رابعا
لعدم اقدام الشباب على تكرار هذه النوعيه
من الجرائم
مطمنين في العمل كنا الوقت تبعتها يعني
كان كل البنات ماشي بقى معلقه ولا ما
بتنزلش وكده لا مش قوي لان هي القررت بعد
كده كتير مش مره واحده بس قررت بعد كده
كتير ورغم ان هم قالوا قبل كده انهم
هياخدوا حكم الاعدام بعض القرار برده ما
حدش سكت ستبقى صورته نيره اشرف المرسومه
على جدران جامعه المنصوره حيث قتلت
كاتسكار دائما لجريمه بشعه هزت المجتمع
فيما يظل التحدي الحقيقي في ضروره معالجه
الاسباب النفسيه والاجتماعيه وراء انتشار
هذا النوع من الجرائم احمد عثمان العربيه
مدينه المنصوره محافظه الدقهليه
في نهايه نشره تذكيرا بابرز العناوين
مع دخول الصراع شهره الثالث الجيش يتهم
الدعم السريع باختطاف واغتيال والي غرب
دارفور والامم المتحده تحذر من جرائم ضد
الانسانيه في الاقليم
في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه موسكو تتعهد
بالقضاء على الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد في
مكيفان تحقيق مكاسب على الارض
رئيس بلديه ميامي يترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه عن الحزب الجمهوري
لينضم الى عشره مرشحين اخرين في مواجهه
ترامب
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات